hey guys how's it going so I'm obsessed
with holidays but not your normal
everyday holidays like Christmas and
Easter but I like the weird celebrations
of days I was going through this list
and I saw one that was middle name Pride
Day yeah those are the types of holidays
that I'm talking about now the thing
with middle names is I don't have one
guys here a fire truck fire truck what
is this where are the fire trucks in
student City what I need them they're so
expensive
my entire life I've never had a middle
name and that's completely totally
normal to me because the crazy thing is
no one in my immediate family has been
either my sister's smell middle name my
mom dad no middle names
I believe my dad actually thought that
he had a middle name for pretty much
half of his life and two he saw his
birth certificate but the first time and
was like where's Romilda don't have one
whoops I don't think ever actually got a
clear answer as to why no one in my
family has a middle name so I'm gonna
get to the bottom of this and I'll get
back to you guys so this always posed
some problems on forms or papers or
tests maybe there's always that middle
name Bach and sometimes I would leave it
blank because I don't have one click
Submit you forgot your middle name no no
I don't have one what are you way to put
here so I've been known as Justine ex
use Eric I would just put an X there
like what else am I supposed to put
maybe I should start putting a little I
[Music]
for some reason the letter boxes always
like to cut off at 6 so I can't ever fit
that 7th letter of an e she will
determine the fact that I am NOT a man
Justin who's there Justin here that's me
no Justin it's me I've just seen me
there's a e at the end of my name anyway
middle name Pride Day was March 10th
it's already past so I'm celebrating
today with my no middle name brought out
her from you guys is what is your middle
name do you like it do you not like it
if you could choose your own middle name
what would you choose I think I would
choose
[Music]
I've had my entire life to figure out
what I think that I would want my middle
name to be and you know what I think I'm
okay with was not having one I know many
of you wish that you probably didn't
have one either but well still kind of
weird to me that somebody names us like
we don't even have a say it's like
you're a fetus mommy daddy gave you a
name and you're stuck with it and you
answer watch it I'll see you soon don't
forget to like this video if you liked
it don't forget to subscribe and I will
see you guys in some more videos bye
that see me rollin with no middle name
Chyna catch me middle name aimless
[Music]